lo que quiero que hagamos en este vídeo
es empezar a dividir por un número de
dos dígitos y como veremos esta es una
habilidad muy importante que usaremos en
el resto de las matemáticas y además es
interesante porque requiere un poco de
arte así que vamos con todo intenta
encontrar cuánto es 186 dividido entre
31 y bueno claro siempre podemos
escribir esto como 186 dividido entre 31
así que pausa e inténtalo ok vamos a
intentarlo juntos voy a suponer que ya
lo intentaste bueno yo no me sé la tabla
del 31 de memoria y creo que tú tampoco
porque si lo supiéramos inmediatamente
tendríamos la respuesta pero en mi
cerebro siempre intenta aproximar estos
números es decir reducir esto a un
conocimiento sobre tablas de multiplicar
básicas lo cual nos va bastante bien va
a ser bastante útil por ejemplo aquí
observa que el 31 es cercano a 30
justo lo que digo cuando tiene un poco
de arte porque como este 31 es bastante
parecido a 30 qué te parece si pensamos
mejor en los múltiplos de 30 es mucho
más fácil porque son los mismos
múltiplos de 3 pero claro tienen un 0
extra al final o lo que es lo mismo los
múltiplos de 3 por 10 así que los
múltiplos de 30 son buenos 30 60 90 3
por 4 12 entonces 30 por 420 150 en
lugar de 15 180 en lugar de 18 porque 6
por 30 18 y observa este parece muy
cercano a 180 déjame ponerlo esto es
cerca a 180 que es lo mismo que 30 por 6
y si esté cercano a 30 y si esté cercano
a 30 entonces tal vez habrá que poner un
6 aquí y voy a ponerlo entre signos de
interrogación porque lo más natural que
seguirían es intentar ver si en efecto
es el resultado
así que averigüemos cuánto
6 x 31 por eso es que pongo este 6 entre
signos de interrogación bien esto sería
igual a 6 bueno la parte padre de todo
esto es que podemos comprobarlo 31 por 6
déjenme escribirlo 31 por 6 es bueno 6
por 1 6 y 3 por 6 es 18 que en realidad
es 30 por 6 que 180 entonces esto me
queda como 186 así que realmente
funciona 186 entre 31 es lo mismo que 6
y ya podemos quitar estos signos de
interrogación
ya estamos seguros muy bien vamos a
hacer otro ejemplo
ahora imagina que queremos encontrar
cuánto es 336 entre 48 336 dividido
entre 48 pausa e intenta encontrar la
respuesta bueno la forma en la que yo lo
pensé es la siguiente vista 48 y me di
cuenta que es cercano a 50 y bueno este
de aquí si lo piensas en múltiplos de 50
tenemos al 350 por 66 300 y tenemos el
350 que es 50 por 7 porque recuerda 5
por 7 35 así que pensemos un poco y es
más déjame anotarlo por aquí 50 por 6 50
por 6 es 300 porque 6 por 5 es 30 por 10
es 300 y por otra parte por aquí tengo a
50 por 7 que es 350 recuerdo 5 por 7 35
por 10 es 350 pero este número está
entre esos dos valores así que estos son
mis candidatos para la respuesta esta
división tal vez a 6
tal vez sea 7 así que qué te parece si
probamos con cada uno de ellos
primero probemos cuánto es 48 por 6 este
es nuestro primer candidato así que 48
por 6 bueno 6 por 8 48 y después llevo 4
6 por 4 es 24 4 es 28 entonces me queda
288 así que este parece ser un poco bajo
para hacer nuestra respuesta de hechos
48 unidades más bajo algo que queríamos
llegar así que probablemente de hecho me
siento demasiado confiado de que el
resultado será el otro 7 vamos a
intentarlo cuánto es 48 por 7 bueno 7
por 8 56 y llevo 5 7 por 4 es 28 5 es 33
336 así que estamos exactamente bien
aquí lo tenemos
tuvimos una prueba inicial mal pero esto
nos llevó a la respuesta correcta ahora
podemos decir que 336
dividido entre 48 es igual a 7 y justo a
esto es a lo que me refería con que
tiene un cierto toque artístico